in 1978 carmen gallante goes back to
prison for violating parole
they should have held him there clearly
because he was consorting with
criminal associates violating parole
but roy cohn got him out of prison in
record time
so he got let out early 79 how that
happened i don't know
he became very cocky and amazingly
he goes on 60 minutes and his lawyer
roy cohen gets to interview him and
present this simple italian
man who likes only to be growing tomato
vines come on to the country
good what are you gonna do when you get
to the country well i mean uh i plant
peppers last week now i'm gonna plant
tomatoes and this completely phony
picture of this mob boss
is ludicrous you think that had an
influence on the federal judge when he
held that you were right in the parole
commission
oh i think so he thinks the farmer ought
to be able to seed right i think so
i mean it's very well known that that's
what i do
[Music]
when he made those stupid moves on 16
minutes act like an old man
they thought well you don't fool a
nobody man forget what you're talking
about tomatoes wear an old hat rip
sweater
you can't do this you can't go public
don't work that way you don't you don't
supposed to do that
he had his own rules his own ways of
doing things
he was earning money he was also
skimming money
but the mafia operates to make money and
in order to make money
you have to follow the rules if you
don't abide by the rules there are
repercussions
july 12 1979 was a very hot day in new
york
and a cadillac was rumbling its way down
streets of bushwick brooklyn
there was a lot of street life going on
it was a typical day
in bushwick
this cadillac makes its way down
knickerbocker avenue
and stops outside joe and mary italian
american restaurant
run by cousins of carmine galante
[Music]
engelante who was well known there made
his way to the back and there was a
backyard garden the bodyguards he
had taken with him that day were cesari
bon ventri and valdo amato
and mood was set for a relaxing
afternoon
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
i was in an unmarked police car by
myself and i happen to be
just a couple of blocks away from
knickerbocker avenue
when i hear this job come over 785
shortly before three o'clock this
afternoon blue chevy pulled up here in
front of joan murray's restaurant
three men got out wearing ski masks
armed shotgun's automatic weapon
and as i get there i run into the
backyard
i'm the first detective that it was
maybe three cops
i see the dead bodies there are multiple
gunshot and shotgun wounds he said as a
result of those wounds would you say the
death
was instantaneous on both hearts it
would appear that the death was very
[Music]
rapid
my mother called me
screaming they killed him they killed
him they killed him
my mother was destroyed
she was just destroyed because she loved
him
she never stopped loving him she loved
this man
it amazed me but it was true
[Music]
it was almost surreal the whole thing
i don't think he thought he would ever
die
[Music]
he's got that god complex
he just didn't think anything could ever
ever happen to him
[Music]
i was very surprised he wasn't killed
much sooner and that's probably why i
was so shocked when he died
because now you don't expect it anymore
because it didn't happen for such a long
time
and there was the wake which was a joke
it was a zoo
report is
for the fbi it was a big mystery why he
was hit who was the killer
that had to be pieced together
there was no love loss when he passed
away there was 40 people at his funeral
there's a reason for that nobody liked
[Music]
him
[Music]
you